je vous dise évidemment le sexe la
violence et la bagnole n'ont jamais fait
de mal à l'audience il ya plus fort
le rire nous allons donc commencer cette
émission parce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
les plus gros scores d'audience à la
télévision
le comice paraître bizarre mais étirer
le comique pourquoi pas le comique
simplement si vous voulez vraiment faire
décoller l'audimat fait du comique morts
vous savez les chiffres montrent que le
comique mort fait trois fois plus de
points que le comique vivant alors fait
donc donné une bonne petite rafale de
comics mort ça va cartonner comique
morts figurez vous il ya beaucoup de
publicité athée vision surtout pour la
lessive
vous avez vu on doit en manger parce que
nous allons d'énormément lessive
je ne sais pas si on est alors vous avez
par an madame oui je vois vous avez un
baril d'arrière en effet si je vous le
reprend et besoin de deux gardiens
décrit habana y est on est con con pas
prendre de varier de la plaza imagine la
bonne famille à la merci veux saluer les
paroles mais là c'est pas bon en coupe
et on va la faire venir en aide alors
vous avez vous avez le nouvel os mobile
le nouvel os mobile a encore plus blanc
pascal anciens homo il a levé blanc sous
les bouffer valait mieux changer voit le
nouveau à dans les lave
encore plus blanc alors le nouveau il
avait encore plus blanc mathieu blanc
moi j'y ai fait comme couleur c'est
blanc - blanc que blanc je me doute ça
doit être hyper mais plus blanc que
blanc et ce serait comme couleur c'est
nouveau ça vient de sortir
ah bon alors pas alors le nouvel os mots
c'est celui qu'il avait la tâche qui est
caché dans le noeud du torchon un seul à
savoir si on est aussi content ça alors
regardez c'est en vrai la télé nous
n'avons pas une bonne femme qui est un
torchon avec une tâche je sais pas
comment ils font la tâche déjà peut-être
se mettent à plusieurs il ya des
concours ou larry tu parles vos
meilleurs très âgées ou je ne sais pas
qui des animaux je ne sais pas vraiment
un talent sur la morale ça n'arrive pas
à vraiment faut marcher un éléphant ça
ne s'est pas d'éléphants pauvres
n'avaient pas mangé pas de juger encore
fera pas non plus maintenant on tire la
sade
ça va être un bonbon à leur écoute moi
j'ai même puis c'est bon je suis là
qu'est ce que j'aime bien et voilà il se
chiffre à awala m'en fous j'ai les noms
de ceux qui font les congeler non bon
alors vous avez à voilà alors le
pensions alors à lui une otage et
lorient une bonne fin de carré dans le
siège la télé et la bonne femme et c'est
même pas un nouveau logo et lee kun-hee
voisine
elle arrive à l'infini grossesses allant
dans ce sens je m'en fous un nouveau
logo et l'autisme une bonne nouvelle ou
vos ne voulait même pas du tout ça alors
les talibans à marjah
je prends en torsion il ya un gros stade
je fais 1 noeuds 1 noeud en plus du
temps je fais un noeud je me la machine
je sens la chine jeudi fenouillat plus
la grosse tache et l'hôtel si c'est
aussi propre qu'avec l'ancien au mot
quant aux épaules mais c'est plus long
faut faire le ne pas rien celui qu à 5
kg de linge vous faites les nous le
lundi vous fait la lessive le mardi puis
après tu as la semaine menée par le pld
ne pourrais tu es dans l'autre jour à
l'automne
et pourquoi tu tousses alors voilà
pourquoi je t'appelle je suis au petit
café à côté de la douane là oui je suis
en face du secrétaire aux touches f
douaniers et où il est le bicarbonate
abbaye risquez rien il est dans les
mains du secrétaire aussi chef douaniers
à lotta pas pourquoi tu tousses oui elle
relaie pourquoi tu t'appelles trois fois
rien c'est bénin bénin bénin bénin
tu sais les 20 kg de bicarbonate mais
alors lui douaniers les accusés il
s'avère qu'il ya 20 kg 500 grammes puis
alors il peut payer une petite taxe pour
les 500 grammes de france en quarts
c'est pas cher alors le reçu est-ce que
je dois le mettre à mon noyau attendant
c'est pour ça que tu appelles tu encore
oui c'est le but
c'est le but de mon téléphone c'est pour
ça que je t'appelle tu entends pas ce
que ton adresse exacte c'est bien 235
cours belsunce à marseille 2e étage
porte à gauche
non bon et ben écoute
la taxe est je la mettrais à mon nom
oui il ya le douanier qui rigole dit
c'est bien la première fois que je vois
rigoler un douanier d'une façon aussi
intelligent sinon alors une petite
anecdote trois fois rien tu sais qu'ils
ont analysé le bicarbonate a longtemps
pourquoi tu tousses ça n'est pas du
bicarbonate ses 17 euros de l etat
pourquoi tu tousses plus hier un journal
télévisé j'ai été saisi dans le bourdon
c'est ma seule j'ai bien vu pouvons
d'avoir il avait une petite vie
aujourd'hui ça va encore mieux à bruel
télévisée une angoisse
on est malheureux dépit new york yankees
club de faire de même chez nous
maintenant et c'est nouveau pour nous
même des plats présentés pas de misère
c'est à dire autant une petite erreur
dans votre série de comics mort il ya
une petite erreur laquelle fernand
raynaud n'est pas mort assis à si si je
vous assure enfin moreno abba autant
pour moi c'est un peu regrettable
il est mort et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus